you can always get a little shoulder
work in there no matter where you are
you you this is all this is the only
space you need to get some shoulder work
you walk about to go meet your Smith and
say we're joined by this amazing shoe
Mitch amazing journey by are you
finished amazing
I'm feeling pretty pretty pretty shoe
yeah man I mean look I'm living my dream
guy ever since I was a little kid like I
think all of us I dreamt up being a
superhero now I am ever since I was an
actor I dreamt of portraying one yeah
now I am like it's the mind-blowing
Mooji it's that guy he's like she that
kind of I yeah but you like just living
your best life I'm trying to I hatched
hashtag treat yourself
I was already you know getting back into
the gym and trying to you know take my
own life and health back and then all of
a sudden I got the job and then that was
ramped up to 11 and I was I was in the
gym six days a week for the last year
and a half now and trying to be the
healthiest strongest me that I can and I
feel like I am right now
and I feel like this is all happening at
a time in my life where I don't know
it's you know it's been a 20-year career
and they always say it takes 20 years
for an overnight success yeah so high
world
you've never home nice I mean the body
is looking banging in it thanks man
appreciate it I'm just like how much is
that because pot me for is it kind of
like one of these things where you just
like blow up with a straw and then you
have the are like wow are you talking
about like like what like the the
floatation devices on planes when it's
like you guys if it doesn't inflate just
use the Strong's yeah by the way if any
of us ever were in a non inflated if
like we got it we jumped into the water
if we actually survived a plane crash
and then we were jumping out of the
plane and we were in the water and this
then didn't turn on you would be
freaking out so bad trying to blow that
thing yeah we all this suits this vision
about how much was a black and how much
was a pate sure all of it it was it was
everything I was busting my ass right
you know put on this physique but the
suit had to be built in a bunch of
different ways for a bunch of different
reasons in order to build a practical
lights like we had on the chest there
had to be a plant but between my skin
and the electronics so you had to put
stuff in there the shoulders are a
little bigger than I would have made
them but you know the shoulders
the shoulders one thing I took away from
this is item for the DC world is kind of
like the Kardashians explain because
it's kind of like this just sunk tional
family and they've all got different
personalities all right way which card
actually would I be not Kylie haha damn
it damn it
[Music]